[Musique]
cyrille melchior et maurice gironcel
signent le pacte de solidarité
territoriale sainte-suzanne devient
ainsi la neuvième communes de l'île à
prendre part à cette convention porté
par le département de la réunion 2 7
millions d'euros seront alloués à des
projets d'investissements et 650 7000
euros pour des projets sociaux qui dit
par des solidarités qui dit
investissement que dit également relance
de l'activité et le btp
vous savez il y en a beaucoup besoin et
c'est l'activité ce travail c'est la
population qui travaille
et c'est mieux ainsi c'est donc là aussi
participé en quelque sorte au
développement économique de notre pays
le centre communal d'action sociale de
la commune proposera grâce au
financement du pacte de solidarité
territoriale un service innovant le tati
sociale ce transport adapté sera mise à
disposition des personnes fragilisées et
isolé servir à faire les cons ça
sentirait rejouer en l'otan amis
quand je suis avec madame de gagner
comme ce matin à parler cela me touche
énormément et je me dis que peut-on
faire pour venir en aide
il a compté une solution est bien la
solution notre mutualiser nos moyens
commune département on peut la trouver
ensemble et ensemble ont conçu des
dispositifs
c'est ça qui est important venir en aide
par la proximité à nos populations des
pilotes le président du département
s'est ensuite rendu à saint benoît le
maire de la commune jean claude fruteau
signe à son tour le pacte de solidarité
territoriale
une enveloppe d'un montant de trois
millions deux cent quatre mille euros
sera mise à disposition par le
département pour le développement de
projets de proximité dans un premier
temps
kazakhs
la culture
éducation culture et des questions mais
patrimoine deux mondes patrimoine et
la qualité de vie les élus se sont
ensuite rendus à la mairie annexe de
sainte anne un site qui sera réhabilité
en partie grâce au financement du pacte
de solidarité territoriale
[Musique]